if you fall off a horse you get right
back on right well prince harry put that
saying into action as he took a tumble
during a polo match in santa barbara on
sunday
that's the duke of sussex riding his
trusty stallion alongside his polo team
los padres sporting his uniform a green
shirt white pants and gloves but at one
point during the match the horse lost
its footing and both of them hit the
ground then harry consoled his trusty
companion with a pat on the back as he
picked himself up and while harry's team
lost the game he seemed unaffected
sharing a sweet moment with his good pal
and polo teammate nacho fagedas wife
delfina the family seems to be close
with the sussexes back in may nacho
gushed about playing polo with harry
sharing this photo of the two and
writing in the caption what a joy to see
you smile and be so happy i love being
your teammate vamos and last year nacho
opened up to ellen degeneres about
harry's competitive side he's a little
bit like you right very competitive
he um he hadn't been on a horse for two
years and he gets to aspen and he says
well you know i you know my back i'm i
haven't been on a horse for a long time
so i'm going to take it easy it's going
to be great and then you know the second
we got on the horse he was like hit me
the ball like come on come on like so i
that you know i love that about him yeah
he's very competitive
harry's wife meghan markle and their two
children archie and lillabet were not at
his match on sunday but it's been a busy
month for the family they just returned
from the uk where they celebrated queen
elizabeth's platinum jubilee
during the four day celebration the
queen met lillabet for the first time
after the trooping of the color event
this was megan's big moment draped in
white dior for her first formal public
appearance in the uk since mexic she
held hands with harry for much of the
time there were smiles for the cameras
cheers and a few boos from the crowd
less than 15 months after their
bombshell oprah interview the event also
marked the queen's reunion with baby
lily's big brother three-year-old archie
who hasn't seen his great grand since
his parents stepped away from their
royal duties and moved to the states she
hasn't seen archie for nearly two years
now and she hasn't seen harry for well
over a year so she will have been i'm
sure delighted to have got to see him
and megan i think the queen particularly
given that she's not 100 at the moment
would have just wanted this to be a warm
encounter and you know we'll hope that
this will be the first of many visits
back to the uk lillabet also celebrated
a milestone during her first trip to
dad's home country her first birthday
megan and harry shared this sweet candid
shot from her birthday bash that's lily
wearing a baby blue dress and white bow
her red locks just like her papa on full
display
[Music]
you